[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the best hair in all the
podcasts and what podcast Lord Taco
Barry quarter I'm Brad welcoming to yet
another
episode about very little Berry Taco how
are you guys the show that won't go away
yeah
please God go please God yeah how are
you guys I'm doing great doing great you
know uh what is that going on behind you
wait you're on the bus Taco what's
happening
no this is uh this is where I do the uh
twitch streams from oh my God we're
inside of his homeland Barry there's
going to be a little blue princess on
that screen right behind him yeah keep
watching a blue-haired mom out of a
closet any moment now Hey Barry do you
know what's crazy how long have have I
known Taco I've never been to his house
wow that's crazy I've never been there
either it's like Barry you have to leave
you vary the state yeah Barry it's a
different state you're not coming
um but of all those times like the only
thing I think I did they showed up to
your your driveway once I think that was
about it I think so yeah yeah did he
meet you did he come running out did he
come running out and meet you yeah yeah
I actually went to Brian Stone's house
the other day and he wouldn't let me in
he said text me when you're here I'll
come out yeah Taco wouldn't let me in he
sent one of his ladies out
um and the thing about Brian's house is
is that uh the reason why he won't let
you in is that you know he's got some
sort of body in there I mean he's got
sort of I'm not saying he's Jeffrey
Dahmer I know what you mean by Body I
think he's cutting up some sort of
raccoon in there it's a former fashion I
know what you mean by body
yep I've been in his garage that's the
closest I've gotten
boy all that sounds really sexual
everything is that you just sounds very
oddly oh I got in this garage and picked
up this carpet
that's what you mean by Body there's
somebody in there and he can't remember
her name
he doesn't want to have to try to
introduce you
[Music]
I'd let you in but I don't know her name
so yeah I'd have to go through this
whole thing again I have no idea who
this person is That's So Good by the way
I'm wearing a jacket let me take this
jacket off yeah you're looking a little
music
[Music]
do you look like a priest what is that
what it's a black shirt Barry is that
okay off duty makes me put the jacket
back on
makes me a little nervous did you say it
off duty priest yeah at the end of the
day type it took the collar off okay
wait a second I know but you you are the
Catholic one you and you can tell me
what's right or wrong but is a priest
ever off duty no technically no
when the collar loosens they're kind of
that's about as close as they get though
they get some off priest hours so they
hit up the clubs down pop that collar
get some beer and go cruising for babies
go drink
totally different meaning for Pop That
collar yeah I uh yeah I'm learning more
about the Catholic faith as I uh
live and breathe uh so
I guess that's the show uh we'll talk
next week good talk as always good good
seeing you guys
uh so what do we have this week what do
we uh what do we want to explore what
kind of topics do we want to dive into
dad well I by dad I assume you mean me I
think uh I think I'm kind of excited who
else would I be talking to I want well I
don't know has anybody else acquired the
dead nickname in this room I'm willing
to pass it on
um I'm actually excited I'm excited
about next year's Festival season I
we've had several conversations within
what the last 10 days and uh I think
Russ and I and you I know you and I
talked and then Russ and I talked and uh
I think we have some pretty cool plans
in place and I'm I'm ready to to get
ready for next year are you wait are you
booking a festival what kind of yes what
kind of plan do you talking about it's
going to be on my front porch because
I'm never leaving the house
no we have some ideas for the show that
uh I'm pretty excited about uh we kind
of launched one this week
and uh well the first question is and
always is the first question
how does this affect me
there's not a lot of work for you oh my
God then I'm in that's why it's gonna
work oh my god I've never been happier
in my life that's why it is the work's
already done the work is already done
and uh that's why it has a chance we
don't have to rely on
that's why we it has a chance what we're
gonna do uh we've been talking with the
folks at consequence and then among
ourselves and we've realized we've been
doing this four years going on five and
we have a lot of great material uh in
the bank
and so what we're going to do is go back
no money
but material different kind of Bank cash
yeah
yeah no money
but we're gonna go
somebody's bank is not somebody that
ours is we're gonna go back and listen
to some of our previous shows and pull
clips and
um
and put those out as bonus material on
during sort of this quiet time I mean
let's be honest there's the big
festivals are done the the rumor mill
will start up pretty soon and then in
January typically we'll announce They
will announce rather we'll start getting
Festival lineups and that's kind of the
beginning of our next season
but we thought we have all this material
and it's all I call it Evergreen it's
it's just as relevant today as it was
when we did it you know with band
interviews and Industry people
interviews and so well I mean maybe not
our Bonnaroo picks maybe that's not
right no no
let's go back to my 2020 picks
yeah we're not going to go back to that
or you know who's on the lineup or who's
not on the lineup those things won't but
but when we interview a band that is on
you know a 2019 or a 2020 lineup we
didn't necessarily talk about that
Year's Festival we talked to the band
about their music so it's still still
relevant so
um we're gonna start putting that stuff
out and uh like how much content are you
talking how many like how long are these
little Snippets gonna be two three four
five minutes I think five is probably a
good number well you know if it's five
minutes we could call it a high five see
I think that's a great idea we could
call it the what podcast I didn't have
any responsibilities here whatsoever
you're the idea guy you're a giver you
know if you in fact if you had if you
did two maybe it's a five minute and a
five minute you had ten minute segment
you could call it a double high five
double high five see that's why you're
the that's why you're the man cash of
credit it will be cash or credit yeah
show up give the idea and disappear yep
yeah after you draw up with the idea
yeah we got to do the work bye-bye and
then we gotta do the work yeah yeah I'm
excited about my entire career that's
been my entire career and look at you
look at you look where you are now no I
love that I love that idea
um uh the uh the other thing too that I
would like to Chronicle probably is
maybe you know in the corner of the
screen you maybe give like a hair rating
you know what Barry is for that day out
of a you know out of a five maybe
berries a four and of course I would be
a five
[Music]
um
you know yeah
his Taco was in two I was getting ready
to say it'd be a whole lot like tacos
PBR ratings never never less than a four
never a five yeah that's a four it's a
four it's four out of five I mean it's
just PBR okay out of that you know
that's a great point you know you put
one of these out last week right and it
was with Ashley Capps right yep okay so
I'm sure Taco you listened to it you
watched it out of five how many stars do
you give that snippet
that was a five
oh wow I thought it'd be a four
I thought they'd always be forced it's
not PBR no it's even better than PBR
how about that we still haven't won an
award
how was there not some sort of like
podcasting you know Festival podcast
award not you know been given to us I
mean isn't there like the federal
podcasting commission that could you
know call us up and be you know what
we've we've looked at every Festival
podcast there is a universe out there
but you have to pay to get in it's like
500 to enter back to that money yeah
Bank thing I I think we deserve a blue
ribbon we do
wow you know what I mean I think that
everyone put that on the logo we need to
figure out if it's a blue ribbon episode
I love that maybe it's a you know you
have to tell us you have to tell us if
it's a good enough episode taco
yeah I'll review them oh okay I'll let
you know my thoughts okay and then maybe
let us know if the episode is a baby or
not
clarify just in case if it is a baby or
not a baby because sometimes in this
digital world I have no idea boy let's
hope it's not a baby God I always hope
for no babies yeah
yeah that's a whole nother yeah you know
that as talking though I I agree with
him I thought the Ashley Capps episode
was a five and uh I think it's relevant
because
he talks about the importance of uh
Bonnaroo and what it meant I mean when
we talked to him this was in 2000 and
2018 but we kind of talked about the
beginning of of the festival
2003 and four and uh and what it meant
and it's kind of funny
um
you know I had introduced you to him at
four castle and
you know you made a comment that uh
that got a pretty great reaction from
you you said thank you for saving music
um I mean I uh Hey told him the truth
yeah
um because if if not for Bonnaroo there
would be a lot less bands with an
opportunity
um you know it rejuvenated the entire
Festival scene that would take over the
next decade and a half yeah
um you know not just the festival scene
and I think he and you make the point
that uh People Like Us wouldn't know
about certain bands if it weren't for
festivals Portugal the Portugal the Man
I think was the example uh not the truth
you know it became the the festival
scene created this this attitude of I
want to know what else I want to
discover something that I don't know
about and that's not where music was at
the time and so it's I thought it was a
great answer and a really good interview
and uh well I mean I'll be totally
honest I mean I I would never have
fallen in love with with Alabama Shakes
the way that I fell in love with them
and and Brittany if not for Bonnaroo
yeah
um no way I would have found Courtney
Barnett no way I would have found Black
Keys No Way Obama cage the elephants My
Morning Jacket for me sure sure those
guys uh they weren't getting a lot of
radio AirPlay they're now huge I mean
imagine imagine them without the
festival scene
um so yeah I thought it was an important
conversation yeah you get in front of
you get in front of a crowd that you
never were able to get in front of uh
before
um yeah you know and and then it
rejuvenate I'm sorry rejuvenizes an
industry like mine who you know looks
around and especially at that time we
didn't have streaming numbers to go on
we had to go by you know a lot of times
uh gut a little bit of research and then
ticket sales you know who's selling
tickets and if you if you think that you
know at the time Alabama Shakes is going
to sell a ticket uh give me a break but
then they get on a festival stage and
all of a sudden they get exposed to a
completely new audience Off to the Races
um yeah yeah I mean look I don't know it
turns out I tend to bloviate just a tad
bit on occasion uh so you're you could
you could rightfully accuse me of maybe
overstating it a bit but you know I
think that you understand the thread the
point that I was trying to make Oh I
thought it was I thought it was spot on
and Ashley's answer is is spot on and
not to Pat ourselves on the back though
that's exactly what we're doing uh we've
had some great interviews with people
within the industry that he he you know
Ashley being one of them there's a lot
of other ones uh from artists to
Industry people and and we just thought
man we need to find a way to
to get that back out there and in a
short way you can listen to just five
minutes and then if you're interested
you can go back and listen to the whole
thing we'll have links and all that sort
of stuff so good yeah uh especially if
you just found the show if you just
started listening or something exactly
we do have a lot of content that we want
to try to bring up and a lot of inside
jokes that you're gonna have to catch up
on uh because yeah there's we have
really hit the gas on the inside jokes
yep there's a whole vernacular to learn
yeah but it's fun and if you love
festivals it's uh we hope you love the
show and and again to give Taco a bunch
of credit uh he's read he continues to
tweak the website you've added some new
things just this week right
I have uh we have a search now uh
because we've got so many episodes that
sometimes it's hard to remember what
we've gone back to talk about so
search them up we've added some little
time stamps to certain episodes that
have the key time yep big time oh that
is that's very clever look at you uh
the search feature is nice because I
have no idea what we've done I have no
earthly idea I mean Barry brought up an
interview earlier says like I don't
remember doing that yeah I know me
either yeah we're up to like 130
something episodes oh God Almighty
you're kidding me no no stop it yeah I'm
sorry but neither one of you is that
interesting that I want to hear them we
blew past our 100th episode and didn't
do anything special
correct oh man all right well wow sort
of like your Christmas present I can
just do it lately yeah
yeah we'll hit the next hundred how
about that
um all right so outside of the we got a
clip for today we're gonna do a high
five today
yeah but I don't know what it'll be yet
okay good that's a good place we're
gonna have one we'll definitely have one
I think uh I think Russ and I uh Brad
you won't have to do anything so yeah oh
God just keep saying that and I feel so
much better I think Russ and I were
gonna figure out how to what it's going
to look like and all that so we'll
definitely have one for today and then
we'll probably do these what for the
rest of October
and a little bit in the November and
then we are currently lining up
pretty cool guest to kick off uh
November been talking with some of the
folks over at Live Nation about some of
the plans that they have for next year
and uh we're gonna have some guests on
our show that will announce uh
some big changes that they have in store
what do you mean you're being you're
being awfully vague I am being vague
because they're still trying to work out
the details but who is they people that
the folks at Live Nation the people that
put on Bonnaroo okay uh some of the same
people that we talked with uh from Moon
River
the local Chattanooga Festival it's all
kind of Live Nation C3 AC entertainment
um we had uh good experience with that
and out of that we've been having some
conversations and
and they want to come on our show and
talk about some big changes that they
have planned for next year and okay that
also is part of the reason I'm I'm kind
of re-energized about the whole
thing experience I you know I was
thinking about it this week we we talked
about
heading into 2022 Bonnaroo that this
felt like a reboot kind of year
that because of the pandemic and all the
different the economy all the different
things that it just felt like
this was a a year that people who put on
these kind of events were gonna
take stock at the end and figure out
what worked and what didn't work and I
believe that is the case I think that's
and I know I'm being vague but I think I
think that you're right well yeah you
are being vague but it is I think that
you're right I I just do I I don't know
if I'm as confident that it's going to
get any better next year
um I do think that you know boundary is
gonna have a much better year and uh
maybe Coachella still be fantastic and
you know the when we are Youngs are
still going to exist and pop-up but I I
just I don't know if
the
the
the
ground
changes shifts all that much when it
comes to this kind of stuff
um
the numbers the big one the fact that
there are so many and they're all going
to change
specific no I think I think you're still
gonna get lose a lot of festivals and
it's still to stay very very hard to do
in fact weirdly enough my company just
announced a beach festival in Miami and
I mean I I was just on the periphery of
a lot of the planning of it
um with no real responsibilities
whatsoever just like I like it and
yeah I know it's perfect and and I
watched how you know difficult it still
was even to this day to find
um the right artists at the right money
everybody is so booked and everybody is
trying to get what they can and I'll be
honest it hasn't stopped even through
the first of next uh year the first
quarter of next year is just as busy and
just as overloaded with five six seven
holds in some rooms
um I don't know I I don't know if it
lightens up and I don't know if it if it
gets unclogged
I just don't know I don't disagree with
that it's a macro versus micro thing I I
I guess I I agree with you I think we'll
probably lose a lot I think that the
economy will fix that the market I guess
what I'm thinking of is we have too many
to begin with correct I what I'm
thinking of is the ones that will
survive are the ones that are taking a
really hard look at how they do things
as it relates to the Fan Experience and
the ones who figure it out and fix it
are the ones that are going to survive
and and I guess that's where I'm coming
from and
we'll we'll talk about that I mean I
yeah you know we we have the reason we
do this show is because we've all agreed
that that's what we think Bonnaroo has
done well they look at things from a a
Fan's perspective
um
and from what I'm hearing and what I'm
gathering they're they're taking a hard
look at that and we'll see if it works I
mean they they still you know they're
they're the ones who are asking people
to camp in a field in Manchester
Tennessee
you know that's that you're asking a lot
uh and I think they're trying to figure
out how to how to make that work and
more appealing and
they're going to come on our show and
talk about it so good yep well they're
welcome anytime
um as are any Festival organizers that
would like to come on and chat we'd love
to have the content I uh promise you you
are going to be welcome here on the what
podcast Indian all Festival coordinators
organizers Bookers
accountants ticket takers car Parkers
valets we'll take them all just take
them all come on be fun just just be
funny
um so there's other uh there's another
thing that I thought that we wanted to
to bring up oh yeah but about your
vagueness though
um you're you're dancing around you said
changes what what kind of changes are
you speaking of structure uh this will
not I don't think we're going to talk
about lineup bee type of things uh at
this point but uh just just how it's
organized
um
from the fans perspective so I I don't
want to get in I don't think I can get
into it any more than that because
there's still a lot being hashed out but
uh
it will be significant I mean if I mean
you haven't said anything to me but if I
had to guess I mean I think that there
are probably a you know three and a half
a dozen things that the normal body
Ruben even the guy that didn't go uh can
probably go down the list and say yeah
that's probably what they're going to
address next year I think that some of
these are low-hanging fruit that we can
all probably assume are going to be
fixed
unless you completely you know blind
yeah I mean
I mean what was the biggest topic last
year I mean I'll go ahead and what was
the biggest chatter last year
the second toll booth or the second
entrance I bet that gets fixed yeah I
would I would be very comfortable hey by
the way in saying I bet that gets fixed
yeah by the way what was the um did we
talk about this or not how did you guys
like the Jam tracks
we never used it because
it the word we got was it was just so
awkward it was a what do you mean it was
it was a singular Loop
and it was I don't understand uh so it
was just it sounds like it was a hamster
wheel well it was so
oh you're talking about the loop around
around the camp area got it okay so if
you got on it's a
Plaza one you had to go all the way
around to 10. and it took you know you
could have walked it in that amount of
time really and it filled up right I
mean Russ you probably heard from more
folks than I did I also think they
didn't have enough uh vehicles to get
everybody around so the wait times were
a lot longer
yeah
so I mean
great in theory and it's something that
can can just get better just get fixed
yeah have them going two-way I mean
there's all kinds of you know a lot of
it is really
some of that is probably related if you
remember the Staffing you know the
numbers were so low they didn't have the
same number of volunteers and Gates and
all of that so you know in your in your
opinion and you're probably reading
between the lines and the conversations
that you've had do you think that they
know that
do they know a cause to why the numbers
were down last year do you think they
know why I think they have theories
absolutely okay absolutely but yeah
yeah and quite uh well I mean theories
are one thing do they know what well
everybody has theories I mean you can
theorize how you want to but a company
that big they're not they're not doing
dollars and cents based on theories I
think they have a really good idea yes
okay yes and well if they do because the
reason I ask is if they do
um you know that's an easy thing to
identify as something to be fixed yes
yes and and quite honestly uh I think
I think a lot of it
I felt a lot of that what you're asking
at our Moon River Festival
which what do you mean with as we said
in our last show what three four weeks
ago when it rained out they came
immediately and announced we're gonna
give refunds and then they gave them
within eight days right and they you
know fixed that Sunday night thing now
the Sunday night thing was a partly
because they had Drew Holcomb who was
the curator and you know they're and it
was a small town it was a small effect
event but the the thing that I took away
from that was
they knew they needed to do right by the
fans and they did
um yeah and also I'm sure they had a
staff that was
um large enough to handle the size of
the festival which wasn't that big to
begin with but it was the the staff
wasn't a concern and you know to be fair
Bonnaroo kind of came
I think I know it sounds crazy to say I
know I'm gonna be a blistered for this
but it kind of snuck up on everybody
yeah if you're a company that is running
you know 17 other festivals 50 other
different music venues you know uh and
something's already been well worn in
the past and it's been taken care of and
easy peasy for so many years and then
all of a sudden some new operators have
it and then they look around the
calendar like oh I guess we should um
hmm
that's now huh yeah and things get
missed that way yeah there's a lot that
there's a lot that happened in those two
and a half years and and uh the word I
got was we've learned we learned you
know
um
and and the other point is to I keep
bringing up Moon River but the other
point is it's the same people
maybe not the exact
team 10 but three or four of the ten you
know
um it's it's the same organizations it's
kind of crazy to think that the same
person that that issued somebody a
refund at Moon River is probably the
exact same person that issued a refund
at Bonnaroo from two years ago you know
um it's not it's not like the uh
the job responsibilities changed that
often you know well in actually in some
ways back to your earlier point from a
minute ago it kind of did because they
switched companies and there was a lot
of moving parts and we were coming at
yeah so I think I think what I'm hearing
and what I'm gathering is
they sort of sat back said we we need to
get a handle on this again and and what
do we do and how do we make this right
and uh that's what I'm hearing I mean
I'm I'm hearing positive I mean that
sounds positive yeah so that's what I'm
hearing well you know obviously the what
is it the proof is in the tasting so
we'll see but everything I'm hearing is
uh I know everybody says it's in the
pudding but it's actually the tasting of
the pudding you gotta you gotta anyway
that's deep Lord taka put it on the
board it's another one another one write
it down
it's not just the proof's in the pudding
it's the tasting of the pudding tasting
I mean for a guy that has these sayings
that really don't make any sense the
Exquisite level of detail you have
placed on this specific one is kind of
odd it's a little out of character the
proof is in the
tasting you want to know my favorite one
that everybody says that's wrong
um
and I can't even remember it
good nailed it I just went black okay
I'll think of it keep talking I'll think
of it I mean the one that will never
it'll never get right you know I know I
have heard it now
too many times you know at the time when
I first heard it I said to myself what
did he just say but when our camp mate
about seven years ago looked around was
explaining to us about something he was
he was fishing in a crime somewhere and
he looks like I mean it was [ __ ]
elbows back there and I cocked my head
and I said it's a what I had never heard
that before in my life and that spurred
an entire weekend of us just making up
ridiculous it's like wearing Moon boots
in the desert you know it became the
most ridiculous
hard as I've laughed in forever I've
never heard that before in my life and
you know unfortunately at the time I was
you know just trying to be a dick but
now I've heard it so many times yeah it
was funny
yeah the one I was trying to think of is
have your cake and eat it too the actual
saying is eat your cake and have it too
well that changes everything oh my God
it does no I get it now it makes sense
you can't eat it and still have it but
you can have it and eat it
it makes think about it there you go boy
you're blowing my mind I'm a giver I'm
giving you guys something
uh
um I feel like they're I really do feel
like there was something else and I and
I've totally lost what it was uh let's
talk lineup just for a second because
okay recently dead and Company put out
their uh summer tour and they're booked
on the weekend of Bonnaroo so they're
probably a no-go
I'm glad you brought that up the other
thing too you know I made some pretty
forceful Demands a couple weeks ago and
uh I'm gonna be all for one uh because
rage against machine that's not
happening I mean that dude that dude's
leg is not going to be ready in time for
uh for Bonnaroo so man I I'm stunned
because you were you know you your your
plea was passionate logical I mean I
mean I can't believe they didn't make
the call right then and there I guess
you're not going yeah it didn't work
yeah that's tough
uh yeah so rip
um Brad because I uh I just I I blew it
I blew it oh for one uh you can't you
can't eat your cake and have it too I
guess yeah you can't you can't break
your leg
too so uh the uh the other thing too was
so there's rage there's uh dead and
Company and oh God I thought there was
another one that came around this oh
that's I was gonna say you mentioned uh
guess earlier today man do I think that
I'm really close to maybe the biggest
guest we've ever had on this show
I I really shouldn't I I shouldn't jinx
it like this but I mean it's been said
to me that it is such a sure thing and
whenever somebody by the way whenever
somebody in this industry tells you it's
a totally sure thing I never buy it I
totally yeah using means usually means
he's gonna get fired within the next
four weeks doesn't it well it usually
means that I'm saying this is a totally
sure thing so you'll stop asking you
don't come up with an excuse why it
won't work out later yeah I I had it
arranged but somebody else screwed it up
that's yeah yeah man it is going to be
such a big get and it will I mean
Taco what would be the one
mom that could come on the show that you
wouldn't be able to talk to
like if there was a celebrity mom that
was like I just I can't speak am so
flummoxed there's no way that I could
muster a word yeah are there celebrity
moms I mean Angelina Jolie he's a
celebrity Rachel Bilson is a celebrity
mom well they're celebrities who are
moms okay you know what I'm saying it's
just like trying to we're splitting
we're gonna split hairs that's our new
thing
point being is it's gonna be so big I
don't know if Barry will be able to
muster Woods
don't tease me
I'm counting on it serious hopes up it's
gonna be my Christmas isn't it
you know I've got some really really
good gifts ready for you by the way we
talked about this other year I I have I
have come up with an idea for tacos
birthday slash Christmas and I've told
Barry Barry your thoughts how good is it
oh it's a it's a it's a home run there
might be tears okay oh yeah there might
be tears so so years ago years ago I uh
three and they're usually are it took me
it took me about a year and a half
before I knew Russ's actual name I I
only ever knew him it's Lord taco and so
uh one day for Christmas I decided to uh
look up how to be a lord
how do you actually get the you know
thing of how do you get really legally
become a lord
so you have to own property in England
to be a lord you have to be crested by
the government and own a piece of
property so I went on one of these
websites and I bought Russ a five foot
by five foot plot of land on Hogan Manor
that he is officially just you know on
the uh one caveat that he renounces his
American citizenship and he can then
become the Lord of this piece of
property and officially be Lord Russ
Jackson hence Lord Taco so yes you are
legally a lord should you want to say
goodbye to your friends family and
Country Now that gift was great very
very do you think this gift is better
than the the lordship that he was well I
would just say that that that gives
people listening an idea of the bar
because that's pretty good that's pretty
good yeah so
um yes yes wow well
it's a tad more expensive it's a tad
more expensive but it will be worth it
to watch Russ and it will be a show
thing it'll have something that we can
do it with the show Absolutely so yeah
that's why it's a benefit so that's the
benefit for you know Russ but it's a
benefit for you the podcast listener so
you know if you want to make this dream
happen
um you can venmo me because I
desperately need to fund this idea
why are you getting venmo for my
birthday
but yes anything you can offer me at
Brad stinks on venmo to make this
birthday slash Christmas present happen
um would be appreciated would have to be
in the spring of next year I think it
has to be in the spring of next year
okay you keep saying birthday slash
Christmas those are two different things
and neither of them are in the spring I
know that but if I can present you this
gift at Christmas for the spring then it
would be easy yeah okay it'll be a it'll
be a handwritten coupon dear Russ here's
your gift
okay guys I'm not trying to be Mr New
York all of a sudden but in one show I
have heard the word vehicle and coupon
foreign
vehicle and coupon coupon yeah those are
wrong
look at this idiot it doesn't know how
to say vehicle
all right uh anything I can't even can't
even say Calliope okay I know
thank you
love it uh what else you want to get
into anything else before we go before
you get into the the high five
yeah just yeah I'm excited I'm excited
to see what it's gonna be
you and I know right me too we'll all
find out together go to
thewetpodcast.com and oh hey there's
merch there's merch there too we didn't
even mention that we still have T-shirts
something we probably need to mention
too we don't do a very good job of
saying this but rating and reviewing
always really helps um absolutely you
know you know it's first off if you have
nothing nice to say then
yeah anything uh but you know a a proper
I would say I prefer the five stars but
if you would like to go to the Lord Taco
route and just give four I'm okay with
that
that four stars is very respectable can
I always impressive always room for
improvement
um so yeah if you rate and review uh it
helps and and it turns out and I was uh
talking to somebody who does this for
the company but um there's a difference
between just rating and reviewing just
rating is not good enough the rating
almost is is nice but it really it's the
review that really hits the algorithm
better right so if you have both of
these things then the algorithm sees the
podcast and it populates it in more
places and the more places that we are
populated and the higher we are in the
level that means more venmo money for me
so that I can produce this a plus level
Christmas present for us make this
happen it's all about me yeah I I'm
trying to make it all about you yes all
right
um all right let's get into this uh this
uh high five and uh we'll talk to you
guys next week
[Music]
and for anybody that hasn't ever been to
Bonnaroo the thing that is is remarkable
is a couple of years ago five years ago
or so these things didn't exist so now
you have something to do uh pretty much
all day and all night and it becomes in
and of itself its own its own Festival
its own individual thing which
um I I gotta imagine can end up getting
a little pricey uh at what point do you
start saying ah we're just out of money
we've given you yeah at the beginning
exactly exactly because you guys really
spare no expense and the reason I ask
that like you go to the the house of
love right a couple years ago the place
has done phenomenally well you guys do
not it doesn't feel like you miss a
detail and it what I've always loved
about Bonnaroo is that when you go to
the user experience inside the festival
you can't really find a place where
they've missed a a tiny detail and you
guys really pay attention of those
outside into the the festival grounds or
into the campgrounds and I gotta imagine
at some point you're like well how can
we just do this for free right how can
we just arts and crafts our way to
making this work and that to me requires
an amount of energy bodies human beings
hands creativity that you know can't all
be done with you know just you know
three or four people right
so I mean totally it's definitely a
heavy lift
um we're very lucky that the Columbine
claim and team including Bobby has some
really really awesome relationships and
so it's a balance right like obviously
we have a budget but then we have a huge
plethora of artists that are already
playing the festival that hopefully
because Bonner is a little out the way a
lot of them are sticking around for the
weekend and see these opportunities
there's something exciting and different
and a great marketing moment for them
and so it's a little bit of both it's
working with Bobby and their team to
figure out how we can use their
relationships and people you know
artists on site that are reaching out to
them that might want to do something
different or like Hey we're going to be
there all weekend is there a way to get
a little bit of extra cash
um and then obviously some of it is just
it's just kind of going for the big ones
and just seeing if we even figure out a
way to get them to understand what it is
and to do something different than what
they're normally used to doing
I want to come back
Sophie to to the plazas and all of that
but I want to ask Bob some of the same
questions is it Bobby or Bobby which do
you prefer
oh well everyone's fine Bobby's fine
okay you got it Robert
um I want to ask this sort of the same
question because uh I think these two
things the the events the experiences in
the plazas and the other stage and the
EDM
um are two of the bigger changes that
we've seen in the last four five six
years it's really thrown a breath of
fresh air into the whole thing that's a
huge difference and that's what I want
to come back to but I want to like let's
get caught up with uh Bobby and the and
the EDM stages what was what was your
charge what was the mission that they
said go do this and do it well like Brad
said for free
no I'm sure
you know it's it's interesting because
some of the most legendary and most
talked about sex out of Bonnaroo in the
last 10 years have been those from the
electronic acts you know pretty lights
you know until six in the morning
um dead mouse late night uh bass left
her late night you know some of those
sets are are are categorized as the most
legendary performances of of the history
of Bonnaroo
um so it was only natural to to kind of
give that space its own area within
sinaroo
um and the first three years of of the
of booking this stage it was it was very
much an experiment
um trying to figure out what the
Bonnaroo audience was interested in and
we didn't want to just assume that
everyone liked the same thing
um so we booked a little bit of
everything
um you know we booked the first year
probably you know an act out of every
single sub-genre that we possibly could
to take you know take the the the
crowd's temperature
um but this year I feel like we've been
really zeroed in
um and it takes a lot of of
communication and working in tandem with
Brian and and and Stephen and and Sophie
to really present a a coherent offering
um you know we can't do what we do
without communication so
um you know I need to know what's going
on on the other side of the park just as
much as Brian and Steve need to know
what's going on with the other stage so
it's all it's all one unit moving
towards the same goal so I'm not over
there just booking on an island
foreign
podcast high five to see more of this
and more of our interviews with a
spectrum of artists influencers podcast
people
go to the webpodcast.com or the what
podcast on Twitter is it the what
podcast of the what underscore podcast
it's the what underscore podcast because
somebody already took the name the what
podcast I'm sure he's get I'm sure he's
getting a lot of mileage out of it yeah
they haven't posted since 2016. so let's
see he's he's so good so good all right
let's talk to you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
consequence podcast Network